et vous aurez duster
bon jouer avec nous j'appelle au bonheur
des dames
au bonheur les lames ça va très bien
très bien on fait le grand rex au 19
octobre
voilà exactement et d'ici là enfin en
vacances
bonne idée on répète c'est de faire
pareil parce que pas besoin de répéter
on connaît tous par coeur
ouais on fait un spectacle tous les dix
ans donc là ça fait dix ans donc c'est
le 19 à chaque fois c'est vraiment très
très bien je les connaissais pas je ne
connaissent pas ces individus le 19
octobre
mais moi je serai au grand rex pour les
applaudir quand j'ai connu laurent quand
il m'avait invité dans cette émission là
tu étais là voilà voilà
c'est un ami c'est une fatwa il est là
tout le temps laurent tu les connais les
amis très bien surtout lui c'est lui qui
fait toute ma musique
il ya eu dans l'histoire du cinéma il ya
hitchcock bernard herrmann de le rue
truffaut équipant baffie voilà pour
mettre des dix j'appelle monsieur velvet
monsieur velvet qu'on retrouvera le 31
mai 21 juin drugstore publicis bravo
pour vos copines
merci j'aime ce genre rappelle le bureau
un peu je me rappelle kubrick
j'aime ce genre ça va très bien
qu'est-ce qu'on va entendre là la fin
run to me de beaux mac très bien d'abord
celle par équipes
donc l'équipe des visas tovati parfois
des kits de laurent baffie
je pense qu'il faut faire alors
s'explique c'est gratuit écoute c'est
gratuit
je veux l'interprète d'accord tu es prêt
parti numéro un bravo
fabien
à toi pour les 86 numéro 2
et
jabra
g
numéro 3
non
4 bien bwin
chaque joueur tient sous plagiat berbère
il ya jeu
6 bardot c'est si bon temps
il
c'est maladroit on en est où rebecca 3,3
aulas est très très bagarrer numéro 7
oui
et
guy l'a dit avant petit replay huit
familles
non non je me rends
il est complet
paris
on s'est tu as joué john
9 non
barrot
qui ça
l'ag a way 5 aulas ça remonte de ce côté
là c'est bien à toi non buhari
et
on
oui mais
paris
tous
non la can je venais juste derrière lui
non à cette époque j'avais
l'observatoire c'est les feuilles de
keziah gogoua obama ouais bon mais c'est
bon alors 5 5/10 dans ses bagages
george michael il est dans what we do
qu'elle asseoit répond non réponse c'est
ma carte
dans un mail
à l'issue du plat équipe c'est donc
l'équipe de laurent baffie
qu'est-ce qu'on garde quand la recrue
dans le caisson gagne c'est une fille
claudine fille celle du milieu et
maintenant c'est le chacun pour sa
gueule donc il ya plus d'équipés on est
bien d'accord
1 l'ultralibéralisme
ouais tu piétine ton voisin 1 on est
d'accord ok à toi
m
bien donc ça fait un point pour laurent
baffie bravo ray ventura à toi c'est le
super banco
com
abdon
c'est comme ça
qui
jean parent
patrick juhel tout
ces conneries mais oui car
quand c'est digne
j'organise qui
année
le panier benjamin biolay mon dieu je
l'avais dit toi il a dit il a violé mais
non monsieur ben donc ces pauvres aussi
de la dame le point bravo
je vais à tous francis jours à tous et
maintenant le vainqueur banco mesdames
messieurs attention se concentre
géraldine guy à toi the words words
aia
c'est pas bloqué
gafsa
soit il
black avec son blake griffin à 3 jeudi
et maintenant mesdames messieurs l'ultra
banco glisser un moment de se concentrer
j'ai du mal qui n'agit pas sur mon
terrain
c'est la finale attention tout le monde
se concentre un c'est l'ultra banco
attention il y aurait de fait on est
prêt 1 2 3 dans l'air
il entend
j
m
et voilà c'est joey starr qui remporte
un bon accueil